Aka spider-man aka the spider menace unrest
assured dear viewer good night welcome back
everyone this is my spider-man no way home deleted
scenes video for all the new stuff marvel just
revealed the last couple of days including a
version of tom holland's mcu spider-man venom
symbiote suit because of what happened during
the post-credit scene and the theatrical cut
in a really huge doctor strange multiverse of
madness crossover that was supposed to happen
in the movie so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll be
doing more spider-man andrew garfield and tobey
maguire video soon because they've also finally
started to publicly talk about the future of their
versions of spider-man do we call them variants i
guess you could think of them as variants of tom
holland's mcu spider-man they all said that they
think of each other as brothers but careful for
spoilers for spider-man no way home if you haven't
seen the movie we're mostly talking about deleted
scenes alternate story lines that didn't make the
final cut but you kind of have to understand what
happened to understand what almost happened like
tom holland in a full-on symbiote suit the first
look at the symbiote suit actually came from one
of the concept artists who worked on the movie
you've probably been seeing a lot of concept art
from the movie in the last week in your timelines
it all looks amazing but it gives you a good idea
for all the alternate scenes deleted scenes
alternate story lines and just missing characters
that they were originally going to put in
the movie i've already done a video about
the alternate ending and alternate post credit
scenes for the movie with the venom character
but the writer said that originally they had
a completely different storyline for venom in
the movie and initially he was going to be a
much bigger character like we talk about the
sinister six multiverse villains and there's
only really five of them in the movie venom
would have been the number six and he would have
also originally been fighting with tom holland
tobey maguire andrew garfield spider-man during
that big final battle at the statue of liberty
i'll put a link for that video in the description
below venom was always going to be sent home to
his original universe at the end of the movie but
it sounds like the way in which that was going to
happen and the scene of him leaving the piece
of the venom symbiote behind changed later when
they were finishing the movie a lot of times the
post-credits scenes are the last things that they
film for these marvel movies in the directors of
all the movies not just spider-man no way home but
all the marvel movies usually will tell you that
the marvel people and kevin feige the powers that
be always call the shots as to what most of the
post credit scenes wind up being like the mid
credits scene in the post credits scene because
some of the marvel movies like guardians of the
galaxy too have way more post-credit scenes than
the other films but a lot of times the directors
say that they don't find out what the actual
post-credits scenes are going to be to like
the last minute right before they get filmed for
example the venom let the be carnage post credit
scene with tom hardy's venom getting teleported
to the mcu and seeing tom holland spider-man
that scene was filmed by john watts in
the marvel people not the venom people
so like tom hardy went to atlanta where they were
filming spider-man no way home while that was
happening to do that venom let there be carnage
post credit scene he was also going to be going
to atlanta to film other scenes too until they
changed his storyline during the film but i think
it's easy to understand why marvel did not give
tom holland the actual full-on symbiote suit at
the end of the movie because they really only
wanted to tease that they'd be doing a version
of a symbiote saga in spider-man 4 and beyond or
whatever the college era spider-man trilogy winds
up being wow this feels good in the whole point
of the story in spider-man no way home when you
think about it was about taking everything away
from spider-man taking all the iron man avengers
tech away stripping him of everything turning him
into more of a friendly neighborhood spider-man
like the classic comic book version like the tobey
maguire and andrew garfield's spider-man versions
andrew garfield even says friendly neighborhood
spider-man during the movie talking about himself
that's also why at the end of the movie that new
spider-man suit that tom hans makes for himself
is a version of the classic comic book one it's
just a regular blue cloth one mixed with scraps
from the advanced suit without any of the tech
from before beyond his web shooters that he made
himself in the spare cartridges and since a lot
of you probably seen the movie a couple times you
probably come to the same conclusion but i think
the idea here is that he also saw tobey maguire
and andrew garfield's cloth spider-man suits and
was inspired by them when he was making this suit
so he made this new suit to be more like their
suits also that's probably why his spider-man
symbol looks a little bit more like their
spider-man symbols they're not all exactly
the same like each different spider-man has a
slightly different symbol but now they all look
very similar so for them to turn around and give
him the symbiote right after that would have been
just way too soon so i am totally okay with them
not doing this in the movie and just saving it
for spider-man 4 or whichever movie they want to
do it in and a lot of times when they're coming
up with storylines for future movies they don't
want to nail themselves into a corner or like
pre-determine too many things like they want
to give themselves room to come up with some
different story when they actually start making
spider-man 4. but the biggest other new deleted
scene multiple deleted scenes really features
america chavez if you can believe it that's right
she was supposed to be a really big character in
the movie you can see in these scenes she's a key
part a couple of the major action scenes there's a
scene of her at an amusement park at a bumper car
ride maybe this is like coney island with peter
mj ned leeds flash thompson even and betty bran
and she's wielding a book of magic casting a spell
while everything around them and this bumper car
ride is going crazy the book of magic that she's
holding in this scene was originally what doctor
strange's magic box was going to be you can
actually see in this other deleted scene another
new deleted scene where spider-man is fighting
doctor strange it's meant to be an alternate
version of the mere dimension fight scene doctor
strange throws peter through a plate glass window
of this restaurant and it's meant to be another
big tobey maguire spider-man 2 easter egg for the
scene where doctor octopus throws the car through
the window while he's sitting there talking to mj
zoom in enhancing this scene you can see
spider-man is holding a book of magic
not a box it's meant to be the same book
america chavez is wielding in this scene
i think the reason they changed that the reason
why they made it a box and not a book is they
felt like they were doing the darkhold magic
book in doctor strange multiverse of madness
and the darkhold was such a big plot point
during that movie they didn't also want to use
another magic book as a major plot point in
spider-man no way home i'll talk more about
what's going on with the dark hole during doctor
strange two and we get some more trailer footage
the other deleted scene of america chavez that
we just found out about is during the big final
battle at the statue of liberty she's helping
spider-man fight the sinister six characters
hanging from this crane here and she's wielding
some kind of magical artifact like you can see her
holding this up pointing it at the green goblin on
his glider while spider-man is trying to catch him
the reason as you probably guessed that why
america chavez isn't in the theatrical cut is
because the way they flip the order of the movies
originally doctor strange multiverse of madness
was supposed to come out way before spider-man no
way home let's all try to forget about 2020 and
everything that happened with all those delays not
a great year but we would have seen america chavez
debut for the first time in that movie gotten
to know her character know how her multiverse
portal powers work she can open portals to other
universes other dimensions like it's no big deal
like the way that doctor strange or ned leads in
spider-man no way home opens sling ring portals
they can only open portals to other places in the
main mcu universe with those but america chavez
is currently the only mcu character that we know
about with the natural ability to open portals
to the multiverse without spending billions of
dollars to build a giant machine like iron man
so she's a huge part of doctor strange 2 but after
that movie she would have then been a more active
character in the mcu showing up and other stuff
and she would have showed up to help spider-man
with his multiverse problem having just solved
a big multiverse problem with doctor strange
like here we go again the other big reason for
them not putting her in the movie because they
could have introduced her during spider-man no
way home and it wouldn't been that big a deal
is because she was probably an alternate for
tobey maguire and andrew garfield spider-man
like there was a point at which they weren't
sure whether or not they were going to get
tobey and andrew to come back they did get them
to come back and i'm so happy that they did
but for a little while they were trying to hedge
their bets so they had to come up with alternate
storylines like what do we do if tobey maguire and
andrew garfield don't come back but we still kind
of want to do a multiverse movie so that's why her
in the final battle here just looks so different
like in order for spider-man no way home
to work the way it did they had to get
everybody separately to say yes to coming back
it is just so complicated of course they're
gonna have a couple alternate story lines with
a couple sub characters to put in they also had
to change a huge part of doctor strange's story
line in spider-man no way home when they switched
the order of the movies but i've already done a
separate video about all of his deleted scenes
because of that and alternate endings so i'll
add a link for that in the description below too
and i know there are a lot of questions about
tobey maguire andrew garfield because there's
so many different versions of all the scenes that
they did in the movie like there's literally like
a whole other movie they could release full of
deleted scenes i've already done an alternate
post credit scene video for their characters
originally they were gonna do post-credit scenes
for topee maguire and andrew garfield just to
show you what was going to be happening next
with their characters so i'll also link that in
the description below too i am working on a new
andrew garfield video next because thankfully he
finally started talking about coming back and what
his plans are for coming back in more spider-man
movies in the future yes there is lots of talk
about him coming back i haven't really done a
huge america chavez doctor strange multiverse
of madness video yet because she only appears in a
couple of short trailer scenes but the idea in the
movie is that she's the only person that they know
of in the mcu who can physically portal herself
to other universes and dimensions and in the
movie the whole idea that scarlet witch is kind
of an antagonist like she's kind of a villain
but in the same way that doctor strange was a
villain to spider-man for a hot second during
spider-man no way home like they fought but he
wasn't really a villain scarlet witch is using
her chaos magic power now that she's way more op
and has been studying the darkhold in secret for
a long time to find her children billy and tommy
somewhere in the multiverse but the idea is that
even though her chaos magic is super powerful
she still can't physically travel between
universes without someone's help and that's where
america chavez comes in so for instance there's
a scene here in the trailer where you see doctor
strange and wong protecting america chavez using
this really cool new spell it sounds like they're
trying to protect her from wanda who's just
gone completely off the rails for a hot minute
maybe she's being manipulated by someone else
but either way that's why america chavez is
such an important character in the mcu now i'm
sure eventually we'll meet other characters
like you have kang the conqueror who goes around
deleting entire other universes other timelines
so eventually there will be more characters
who are capable of traveling across universes
there are probably a billion other deleted scenes
that we don't know about yet so there any other
really cool ones that get released or that we find
out about in the next couple weeks of course i'll
do videos for those my andrew garfield video
should be up tomorrow be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that while you
wait for everything click here to learn how they
changed all the timelines of the tobey maguire
and andrew garfield spider-man movies at the end
of spider-man no way home and click here for my
brand new thor love and thunder first look at rune
king thor thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!